today on our show Joker Joker dunkirk
we're gonna talk about the Joker movie
three times and they will appear like in
that other movie were you talking about
the Joker movie and Beetlejuice a little
bit yeah because he goes to anytime you
say someone's name three times they show
up we're talking about on this episode
of fat man I'm Batman
[Music]
well the Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I'm mark barnard okay we talked about
this a little bit on our live show
indeed which happened in john new
brunswick saint john new brunswick
beautiful place if you've never been go
go see it I don't know if we they
videotaped the show but we did a fat man
on Batman there so you could go hear it
if you don't listen to the podcast
sometimes there's stuff on the podcast
it's not actually in the live show so go
listen to that but we talked about some
stuff there but we didn't get to talk
about them here we're do it where it
matters where people could see our faces
we're doing it and doing it well we're
gonna do it hard right here hmm Warner
Brothers and the DC movie unit aka Geoff
Johns and whatnot announced that they're
making a standalone a joker movie yes
out of continuity very important part of
the story yes not the Joker that the
Jared Leto did a new Joker movie out of
continuity almost like that I joke a
graphic novel absolutely
like telling joke which is more like
Killing Joke written but directed
written and directed by yeah by todd
phillips who made the hangover 2
hangover pictures and produced by this
is where [ __ ] gets wild now when you say
like todd phillips like alright well
[ __ ] everybody wants in the comic
book game and even though he wasn't
known for that [ __ ] sure more the
merrier man and that's where the money
is go make those movies the Russo boys
were not known for giant freakin
superhero stories before there was
sitcom directors and here they are but
boom but there's a name that's gonna
that makes you go hmm as we did in the
nineties things that make you go hmm qua
qua pourquoi Martin Scorsese yes
game-changer right there ladies and
gentlemen
right now we who have been loved comic
books for so long gimme your hand me we
who have loved comic books forgive me
other hand it feels better yes me we who
have loved comic books for so long and
sometimes suffered back in the day the
at the fists and arrows of those who
were like comic books grow up the
ignominy of an audience
we didn't care we're now the dominant
culture so much so that the great mr.
Martin Scorsese that one of the greatest
American filmmakers we're the greatest
filmmakers ever do
wants to make a comic book movie that's
where we are ladies and gentlemen and we
almost got married do we their few more
words mark would have been legally bond
and the bonds of marriage but that's
huge that's massive massive and when
that news broke a lot of people like
this [ __ ] old news when that news
broke last week or we could change it
was big enough news then the end of last
week yes last week just before Labor Day
right before Labor Day happened they
dropped a bomb on Stella Oh Leonardo
DiCaprio Leonardo Caprio is in talks to
star as the Joker in the standalone
movie ladies and gentlemen we won the
war is over the imagined war between the
geeks and the jocks that goes back to
like I don't know revenge the nerds
because now the cool kids want to be in
this [ __ ] the cool kids the coolest of
kids Academy Award winner Martin Martin
Scorsese and Leonardo Caprio both of
like hey we should make a Batman movie
wouldn't it be great just give me the
vapors now not because I necessarily
think it's gonna be the greatest movie
ever made but that's where we are man
where the did the big important people
are now doing this stuff
Steven Spielberg into comic book movie
yet but he's doing the radio player one
which is about as close as you get and
in fact includes all the IPS and stuff
like that of some of our favorite films
but to be fair he's been in this world
for a long time he's been in anguish I
mean Close Encounters is now back in
theaters guys he's legend but anyway
everyone wants to swim in the compa pull
with good reason fertile storytelling
absolutely great character DiCaprio he
ain't never played no killer clown no
from outer space or otherwise this is
his chance and he's gonna do it with a
legit background with Martin Scorsese
there yeah with like now you've got
people that would never go near this
stuff going near it but the caveat is
this is part of a next art of the
extended right this will be its own
separate standalone thing like I think
the name they're banding around is
Elseworlds
that they are Wow yeah
[ __ ] Wow there's an entire department
of Warner Brothers films under the DC
entertainment banner that's like
Elseworlds just to make these weird
one-shot standalone crazy-ass Batman
stories and why not and why does it have
to be a continuity look marvel's got the
continuity game down to a science
to a science but one thing they're
probably not gonna do is spin off and
stand alone like you know they'll do
Iron Man and stuff like that but not
like what if Iron Man you know how to
big dick stories where would he put it
in a tin can
so they can do that that's what Warner
Brothers in DC could do the like look
we're late to the game we didn't get the
whole [ __ ] universe thing that Marvel
did god bless him they're doing great
we're trying to catch up with our
extended universe but here's something
that our competitors won't do I mean and
honestly they kind of should have gone
this way from the beginning because you
cannot give a single is important you
you can't compete with Marvel coming his
late to the game as they did Marvel was
nine movies in they were already in
Avengers past where DC was like oh we're
gonna Batman V Superman a Man of Steel
is starting it off and we're gonna
question to Justice League as good as it
was going to be was never honestly gonna
compare no so don't hit him where
they're getting hit hit him where they
ain't go whether or not man look Wayne
the great Walter Gretzky
said to his young son Wayne Gretzky
don't go where the puck is go were two
pucks gonna be this I mean I know a lot
of people when the news first came out
people like [ __ ] Joker movie because
there are a lot of fans who like believe
and let's talk about that real quick you
know look part of the wonder of the
Joker at least on the page is there is
no de facto backstory I don't want one
like the Joker so easy
he's an act of God he's a he's chaos
just swimming in and out he's got no
motivation beyond the desire for chaos
his bet the best representation of the
Joker's origin is in Chris Nolan's The
Dark Knight yeah where every time he
goes to I don't know how I got these
scars and he tells a different [ __ ]
story that's terrifying knowing you'll
never get to the bottom of that [ __ ]
well make some more mysterious make some
interesting so the notion that they're
gonna tell an origin secret origin story
understandably made some people pissed
off like [ __ ] this movie first off let's
be honest we're all going
you know I'm saying we keep mentioned
scream about the Joker's origins much
everyone in comics we're all going
whether it's a cool whether you think
it's a cool idea or not you're gonna
want to see this particularly based on
the pedigree they're bringing out now I
like Todd Phillips I'd like like things
that he's done but when I first heard
Todd Phillips I was like all right well
sure yeah I was not like oh my god
the moment they throw in square says I
was like come again and the moment they
put up Leonardo DiCaprio that's huge
that's everything that's that's you
could have a movie that's as [ __ ]
grand as the Dark Knight I mean
according to The Hollywood Reporter
pizza that we're pulling from part of
this was all Warner Brothers desire to
get a star of Leo's caliber into them
they can't get him into like the
extending you like they were lucky to
get Will Smith yeah into Suicide Squad
as part of the extended universe but a
lot of stars that aren't gonna want to
play that game totally look I don't want
to commit 10 years of my life or like
three movies I'll do whatever you get
you want and you get this but apparently
like so they went after Scorsese
explicitly so this Scorsese could get
them somebody like leo and now with Leo
in the picture it's gotten Jared Leto a
little bit shitty about it what what do
you mean well again according to this
this I'm reading from The Hollywood
Reporter this play was not met with
applause in all quarters insiders say
Jared Leto the actor who played the
Clown Prince of Crime unless I'm a
Suicide Squad was caught off guard by
the plans wow I look like I think we
were all caught off guard by the totally
letter was said to have made his
displeasure with the notion of multiple
Joker's known to his CIA agents and
rival agency WME has been using the
concern to court him like he's kind he's
a lot of pissed because and I get it he
was told when he signed on you're the
Joker yeah you're not one of many joke
but the argument of the to many Joker's
hey man there's always gonna be multiple
Joker's you think Mark Hamill was
butthurt when they were like oh Jared
Leto's playing the joke or even Heath
Ledger's playing the joker like you know
there's plenty of plenty of room now to
be fairly
sinem at this is the first guy that's
had to deal with the fact there might be
another cinematic Joker that somebody
could hold up next to his performance
not before not after but contr the same
time they can a be that [ __ ] I like this
one better than that one that would make
things a little shitty for Leto or
maybe it ups his game in the next one
but to be fair he was like you know we
don't know what he did in the first one
because they chop-chop that movie to
death yeah so who knows but I could say
you know what now putting through that
prism I could see him getting a little
shitty I mean like but he was promised
he's a dude he's a full-tilt diva
if we're gonna bother good idea it's a
good idea it's a good idea but he was
promised a spotlight and he doesn't look
like a dude who wants to share it
no probably not alright so that's the
only downside but let's talk about the
notion was Jared Leto aside for the
moment Leonardo DiCaprio planned the
Joker this is a guy who like slept
inside a horse and got [ __ ] by a bear
for his art this guy he breathes he
lives breathes and [ __ ] I don't every
once in a while I see him on a boat he
hangs out with models and [ __ ] but all I
know of Leonardo DiCaprio in this world
is he is a hundred percent committed to
his craft he won an Oscar for most
acting he is the most the most leo
but think about it like that's for the
first time since Heath Ledger
and that was since the first time since
Jack Nicholson you've got somebody where
you're like do tell right like the
finest actor of his generation and
that's not to [ __ ] on Jared Leto Jared
Leto wonderful actor anyone so right and
he's got his Oscar and we were all
excited when they announced him but you
know now it's like I don't know I think
if I mean I get why he's mad yeah but if
you could put aside that for a second I
think even Jared Leto would be like
that'd be pretty cool to play the Joker
like Scorsese and DiCaprio are like the
new Scorsese and De Niro like it made
five movies together yes why not make it
six I don't know who I'd like to see him
play more the Joker or Batman because he
can bring dimension to Bruce Wayne and
Batman you know what I'm saying that guy
that guy like he I think the energetic
guy he's a family joke around about his
gigs the most acting [ __ ] but like
that's like he's born put on this earth
to it ever since he was a little boy
ever since he was on [ __ ] was the
show they was on with the severs growing
she was on growing pains
you see that's something special and
then when he was in that uh Gilbert
Grape movie like this kids [ __ ]
amazing young boy's life and everything
he does great but he's got longevity on
his side and that works in your favor
and sometimes makes people go like boom
on it [ __ ] like that but take away like
the petty you know stabs anyone takes
this tude
he is the finest actor of his generation
to see that dude take on this [ __ ]
character I take my money take his money
I'm gonna steal his money give it to you
I mean he's already stealing my money
broke his [ __ ] but out of a job your
thoughts I mean like we talked about
before I don't know if I need a joke
removing not entirely sure I wanted your
movie if I have to have one though
ah-ha Martin Scorsese producing a joker
movie period piece set in the 80s in
Gotham City which I'm sure looks like
New York because it's Scorsese yes where
they said they said very taxi drivers
yeah very taxi driver I mean why
wouldn't you want come on wouldn't you
want to see that be a Nazi robot to not
want to see that it's like no no no that
could be a game-changer that could be on
the level of a Deadpool or a Logan this
could be a grown-up movie we could see
an r-rated Joker movie I mean we should
see you know those two cats involved
they better be our way that's that's my
one look up I'll see you regardless but
with an R I want I what is he making
history The Joker snorting cocaine off
of an elephant's ass because why
wouldn't you want to see that that's
[ __ ] cool
that's a movie dear Marty that's for you
yeah this is uh this is big big news you
know is beyond [ __ ] an understand you
know I think yeah like who knows if it
happens this is still very early like
they want to approach DiCaprio hasn't
signed on Scorsese feels attached but no
contracts have been signed yet it's all
in the we want this to happen phase yes
and Warner Brothers has always been
about their filmmaker driven company
they are a we want to ride with Nolan we
want to ride with Clint Eastwood
whatever he wants to do we'll do we want
to ride with Chris Columbus
and the do to director the other for the
Harry Potter movies yeah they are not so
much about franchise management as they
are filmmaker
yeah they like their relationships they
do whereas more yep they ship hard at
Warner Brothers Disney is about execs
they're about like give me your John
Lasseter's give me Cathy Kennedy's give
me your Kevin Feige Gea's have them make
me a universe and then funnel the talent
into this Warner's this find me a
filmmaker find me a writer-director if
I'm if somebody wants to tell a story
we'll let him tell it they're doing it
now and so this feels like the best
synergy of superhero content plus that
approach more than some filmmaker who's
not actually good at universe management
managing universe this is a chance for
them to really distinguish themselves in
a genre that they created yeah the
superhero movie belongs to to Richard
Donner Warner Brothers and Superman the
movie and then it just only belonged to
Warner Brothers for years again they
reinvented it with Tim Burton's 1989
Batman this is a chance for and you know
look Wonder Woman's an amazing movie but
you know it's it's it's Wonder Woman
like and great but like their did a very
traditional kind of telling of the story
of Wonder Woman fantastic movie this is
a chance to do something completely
untraditional that doesn't appeal as a
movie that had to appeal to a mainstream
audience they're now talking about
making movies that appeal to niche and
they know that within Nisha's big bucks
as well I mean if you make this movie
for 80 million dollar bang les 70
million dollar 50 50 million dollars and
they're making all the money back plus
some I'll make four hundred global and
then it's just [ __ ] a cash run to the
bank again I'm a comic book fan so
naturally you know did I feel like
marked I feel we need a joker movie no
but quite like Marc they they had me at
leo mmm thank you hon thank you no coin
that put her ownership is huge newsman a
couple years ago it was huge news when
caliber of actor and Affleck's caliber
ya know when Jack Nicholson got cast as
the Joker it was like the front page of
Time magazine missus he was and this is
what's got to be like going through
Leonardo DiCaprio another [ __ ] dude at
all
but I mean you must think on some level
he's like well Nicholson played this
part and [ __ ] Heath Ledger won an
Oscar playing this part is this any
different than playing The Melancholy
Dane or any of the great theatrical arts
like let me see if I could put my spin
on it so I mean there and to be like I'm
sure it's I don't want to be Cesar
Romero awesome I want to be up here he
wants to reinvent he wants you
I don't think Heath Ledger I'm again I
didn't know that guy at all I met him
once real cool dude but I don't think he
sat there going I want to erase Jack
Nicholson's performance I think he was
just like what can I do that makes this
mine and he did something that that won
an Oscar now maybe Leonardo DiCaprio
looks at that and he goes hey there's a
different way to look at this material
yeah instead of like oh it's a comic
book movie it's like I'm playing one of
the great roles and maybe I could do
something in that role that's different
there's a challenge there like because
it's been essayed by a few different
great talents Ziza Romero Mark Hamill
Jack Nicholson Heath Ledger Jared Leto
like big performances and you get a
chance to be like alright let me see if
I could do something different that
captures the energy of all but like is
uniquely my own and makes people go like
huh the way that Heath Ledger's
performance was like dumbfounded you you
were dumbfounded that forms you're like
oh my god this is the Joker totally like
it's every actor who's ever played
Hamlet is not looking back at every
other actors played Hamlet I'm sure they
like alright there's the big ones
there's the Olivier's there's the the
mel gibson's but then it's how do I make
this mine how do i how do i belong in
this lineage of amazing talent and do
this in the way that's only mine using
the same [ __ ] texts and
reinterpreting it to be me here you'll
get new text but it's the same character
and the character is this strong it's
crazy that we're able have a
conversation about this material this
seriously and compare it to performances
of family but it's true it realizes
we're not talking about content wise or
whatever like Hamlet's time-tested but
you're talking about character there's
now 6070 years old that has moved from
the page to other mediums and has his
larger-than-life character a huge part
that
now they're a really legit actor sitting
there going I want to put mine I was
sink my teeth into this [ __ ] part
yeah I mean it's it's the characters
bigger than whatever actor plays it I
mean we talked about that with Batman
yes like if as Casey Affleck said not
too long ago it's like I'm pretty sure
that this is gonna be the last time Ben
place Batman let's talk about that Casey
Affleck in an interview on a radio
station yeah they're like your brother
playing Batman what's all about it
what's it gonna be like or whatever in
case he was just like he ain't doing an
award he's done with it and they were
like what and he goes oh people aren't
talking about that nevermind it I don't
know Justice League's out in November
now Casey you know Casey did direct I'm
not here the the movie about Joaquin
Phoenix which was something of a prank
yes so maybe he's pranking us a little
bit but it legit sounded like a man was
like that movie ain't happenin anymore
they're like shut up yeah Justice League
forever yeah I don't know anybody who's
making a Batman movie at all with me out
of the loop pay attention that Batman a
Ben Affleck Batman story it just has
legs no go away you would imagine that's
what would be like in Gotham City people
are like you know I heard Bruce Wayne is
the bad like no way [ __ ] guy he's on
a radio show first he said yes no he
said no no you Strunk and there were
ballerinas everywhere heady times many
times but yeah like all of these
characters are bigger than any one actor
who plays them very and that's the point
like you obviously don't need movie
stars for these guys you need the best
actors in the world and Leo is kind of
one of the best actors in the world like
him hate him you can't deny it
you may not dig the idea of a joker
movie but you know what enjoy it because
it's coming coming up your pipe if if
North Korea doesn't come first
so look quit your bitching about a joker
movie they're bigger things to worry
about global warming and thermonuclear
war that movie nothing to worry about
yeah now we could actually be something
I'll just throw this out I'll just leave
this here before we leave okay remember
when they cast Ben Affleck is Batman
Babu
oh then that movie came out people like
he's the best thing and not like he's
the best thing in a pile of [ __ ] they
were like he's really good the the first
you here Joker movie like boo
this could be a great thing you could
see I mean this is with that talent
involved those two Titanic talents you
could see somebody headed toward Oscars
with this [ __ ] Delia Todd Phillips no
what good for it there it is folks from
fat man of bat mouth Kevin Smith Ivan
Locke Bernardo tune in next episode same
bat-time same bat-channel small cast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
joke I joke I joke ah
[Music]
you